welcome back to new rock stars the death
of jabba the hutt has left a power
vacuum in the criminal underworld of
tatooine but after the mandalorian
season 2 final scene boba fett and
finnick shannon are now taking over
jabba's operation in the book of boba
fett is this star wars sopranos or like
the child and the pilot of the
mandalorian is a major star wars cameo
being hidden from all this promotional
material
i try to get in a good sopranos
hey look at us wookie leaks is back it's
new rock stars star wars after show and
big announcement wookie leaks is gonna
be a weekly star wars show on this
channel throughout 2022 we're gonna be
covering obi-wan kenobi and ahsoka
mandalorian season three cassian andor
everything in between i'm eric boss and
i'm back with tommy bechtel
oh god i can't wait
oh man i mean the last time we saw each
other on this show tommy uh uh grogu was
being um kidnapped we were we were two
grown men with tears in our eyes
completely devastated
and also amazed but now we're back we're
talking boba fett but we're gonna be
talking everything star wars every
wednesday maybe a different day of the
week
in between new shows but we're gonna be
back every week and i'm i'm so excited
to be back with you tommy this week
we're gonna be looking ahead at the
seven episodes of the book of boba fett
why is so much being kept from us in
this series how will it connect to the
plot threads from the mandalorian and
ahsoka and where are luke and grogu and
ahsoka during this series and who will
be this grogu style cameo that clearly
clearly is gonna come up in this show
yes yes i think it's going to be uh
a watto
[Laughter]
i mean look we laugh about it but you
know watto is going to show up again
yeah
watto's not done just like every
character in star wars that you think
has done watto it will not be done
they'll yeah they'll find a way to bring
them back uh before we get into
everything keep an eye out for a new
release from our merch partners at epic
hero shop last year even though it seems
like uh five years ago we got this bad
boy but they're gonna be dropping a new
laced obsession shirt inspired by the
book of boba fett so you can grab one
for yourself at newrockstarsmerch.com
when it comes out it's gonna be a
limited edition shirt going to come in a
variety of colors and sizes and when you
grab one of those latest obsession
shirts you'll be getting the added
option to write a custom shout out that
will appear along the bottom of these
book of boba fett after shows so check
it all out newrockstarsmerch.com or epic
hero shop.com uh but tommy what's our
first question as we look ahead at the
book of boba fett well eric i think it's
uh pretty obvious what the fact is the
book of boba fett
what is the show well uh tommy and i are
gonna co-explain this for you we're
gonna tag team it but let's start by
breaking down everything we know about
the series the book of boba fett is
gonna pick up with boba fett after his
live-action return in the mandalorian
season two tomorrow morrison who played
jango fett and the prequels and of
course all of his clones by extension
and therefore uh what adult boba fett
would look like uh is now back in this
universe he actually first showed up in
chapter five recovering the diane
finnick shan from the sans of tatooine
and then we saw his face in chapter nine
on tatooine who while he was watching
denjarian speed off with his armor that
he obtained from cobb vance vance
refrigeration and uh when they slayed
the crate dragon um and then uh boba and
finnick followed them to tython uh in
chapter 14 the old jedi runes where they
uh
reached out to uh luke skywalker we
later learned uh and that's where moff
gideon's imperial forces bombed mando's
ship the razor crest and so the finale
they used the slave 1 in a hijacked
imperial ship in order to board moff
gideon's uh ship and rescue grogu they
were of course aided by luke skywalker
who took the child in order to train the
child and then in the post-credits scene
boba and fanuc returned to jabba's
palace on tatooine where they uh kill
bib for tuna while he was halfway on his
way to becoming yeah the the heavyweight
that chabaha
tuna had not missed a meal he was eating
a lot of fatty tuna i think
not at all and then uh boba took the
throne as uh finnick uh picked up a a
bottle of spatuka and uh drowned herself
in it absolutely well smart move
uh yeah so this seven episode series
will show boba and fedex attempt to
replace job of the hutt as the leader of
the captains in jabba's criminal cartel
on tatooine boba claims that to want to
rule with respect instead of fear
but really using fenic as his enforcer
it seems from little we can tell from
that trailer in addition to tomorrow
morrison and ming now when uh jennifer
beals is also playing a twilike on the
show so i'm excited for more twilights
i've always been mystified by their
pleasure gardens and then yeah
especially uh uh twilight dancer or
whoever she is having an actual
narrative role in it rather than just
being set yes i want to know what her
story is yes
absolutely um
you mentioned the cartel tommy and i
were once part of an improv team yes
only one had like a total of like 45
rotating members over the years
it was it was like minuto
yeah every time i got
stopped being cute we fired them and got
a new cute member
uh yeah and and like in other cartels um
rather than uh people
leading each other with respect it was
led by fear it was every time you walked
out and looked at your seat partner just
pure abject terror overtook us i don't
know what you want me to do in this but
you're screaming at me and i feel like i
just have to let you scream for shouting
so much
[Laughter]
yes well mando chapter 14 updated the
fat backstories so that jango fett was
truly now considered a mandalorian
foundling that was something dave filoni
before had suggested was not the case
both in interviews and a line from the
mandalorian leader almaq in clone wars
but now bubba's mandola chain code
mentioned the armor belonged to his
father jango fett who this chaincoat
said was born on concord dawn and his
mentor was jaster jester muriel who was
a member of the mandalorian clan that
were actually rivals to the death watch
and the watch was of course the clan
that brought up din jarring so just like
a different family of mandalorian uh
warriors and then earlier this year the
animated series bad match came out i
know a lot of you might not have watched
bad batch but actually did a lot to
further update the histories of both
boba fett and finnick shand fenix showed
up in this series also voiced by ming
nongwin
and she was a mercenary trying to
retrieve omega the new young character
accompanied the five members of the bad
batch and first uh fedex shane tried to
take uh omega on the planet pantora in
episode four and then in episode five
the bad batch tried to learn who hired
fenix shand from the character sid on
the planet ordmantel by rescuing the
rancor baby moochie poor job of the hutt
uh via bib fortuna who shows up on this
show
now moochie is not the rancor that luke
fights in return of the jet
but we do see in footage of the book of
boba fett they there is a shot that is
looking up from the rancor pit so i
wonder if muchi could be like another
rancor that were in those stables who is
now replacing the original rancor
moochie
muchi
[Music]
but then in somochie nine a bad batch we
learn actually that omega is another
jango fett clone um another clone that
they can derive genetic material from so
that in a way makes her sort of clone
sister if you consider them brother and
sister they aren't genetically there's
other clones of each other but she's a
cloned sister to boba fett but in this
episode fennek fights the bounty hunter
cad bane and allows omega to escape so
they're on roughly good terms and that
could set up omega to show up as an
adult in live action on this series if
felony wants to go in that direction
yeah
okay i gotta watch more of the bad
batches what i just learned yeah you
gotta check it out all right so the
events of mandalorian seasons one and
two and presumably the events of book of
boba fett are set in the year 9 aby in
the star wars timeline so that would be
about five years after return of the
jedi
in about 25 years before the force
awakens and uh
you know and and then the other ones
that came after the force awakens that
are not bad movies and you need to stop
being really toxic about anyway
luke skywalker spent these years
researching jedi history luke begins
training ben solo
in 15 aby builds a new jedi temple
then in 28 aby luke and ben fight the
temple burns and the voice of snoke or
technically palpatine
lures ben to the dark side i have been
every voice in your head enjoyed your
head
i wish one was uh jar jar
louie's been to the dark side
and then ben takes them the name of kylo
ren which was such a great name and in
mandel chapter 12 in an imperial lab on
navarro they find clone bodies and tanks
that look like early versions of snoke
little baby snokes cue i always dreamed
of being a father and i would like one
day to look down in a bassinet and see a
little baby snoke staring up at me
uh
you mean
like mr burns yeah yeah
yeah exactly and and and voiced by andy
circus uh
so this is all suggesting the efforts of
dr pershing and maf gideon are later
co-opted by what is going to become the
first order we're talking a lot about
the sequel trilogy now and we don't
really know what happens to grosgu
during that sequel future but it is
highly unlikely that kylo ren
killed grogan i did a whole video on
this looking into you know could grogu
have been that grave that luke was uh
yeah the seemed like he was mourning on
toe i don't think that's the case um
because you know if you look at the life
cycle of the yoda grogu species when we
first meet grogo he is 50 but he's still
an infant but we also know that yoda by
the age of 100 was a jedi master who was
already teaching other jedi so there's
going to be a period of rapid maturation
between the ages of 50 and 100 i don't
think we're going to see a lot of time
jumps i think the all these news shows
that are taking place post-original
trilogy are going to be in a few years
of time yeah i don't think we're gonna
jump ahead to beyond the sequel trilogy
at least on this show i think we're
gonna maybe have other star wars stories
that do that but i i mean i don't know i
i think the less grogu and the
mandalorian and boba fett and ahsoka tie
into the first order and the sequel
trilogy events the better yeah you know
i i think the sequel trilogy just let
them do all their thing and right now
we're in kind of this new era of time
that is very exciting and i don't need
to know a ton about how the first order
rose i agree uh i'm happy just exploring
these characters and other story lines
that they're following but i have to
tell you tommy there have been some
rumors that suggest a grogu prop or a
puppet was spotted on the set of the
book of boba fett oh and then this
little uh kiddo is going to be
accompanied by someone else
so i want to ask you do you think grogu
will appear during these seven episodes
and if so
do you think his escort is more likely
to be another luke skywalker vfx
character or could rosario dawson return
as ahsoka tano as his jedi mentor on
this series
i
oh man i really hope it's luke i really
hope it's luke skywalker because i want
to
learn more about what luke was doing
between the end of force awakens and the
end of return of the jedi and when we
last saw him flagging that x-wing to go
pick up
i really hope it's luke i feel like it's
probably going to be rosario dawson
though if if this rumor is true because
it's just
they don't need to
have an actor and i don't know
i just think having an actual person
there is probably
maybe more preferable i don't know i
don't know i just that's just my yeah
they they committed so hard to uh trying
to de-age mark hamill's face and and and
do all that and you know there was that
interesting moment where like he looked
amazing and then he started talking and
some people were like uncanny valley a
little bit and there was that other
youtuber the vfx artist who made like a
better version of it and lucasfilm hired
that guy oh wow which i just love how
that worked out but every year that
passes they're getting a little bit
better on this but it seems like the
lesson a lot of vfx artists and
filmmakers have learned is that um try
to do a version of the character that
doesn't speak yeah or if they speak you
don't see their mouth have to move or
maybe you cover their mouth in some way
and i don't know how they would do that
with luke skywalker if he is going to be
a returning character in these series um
i honestly would prefer maybe just
recast it you know we talked about
sebastian stan you know what kind of
looks like yeah uh
uh mark hamill did a little bit yeah um
i don't know if that's the casting
choice realistically i think um
they want to build up rosario dawson as
a socatano she's gonna have her own
series and if and if ahsoka does show up
in 2022 as a miniseries i hope so
i think book of boba fett is where
they're gonna have to do it um even
though that i i believe hayden
christensen as um as anakin skywalker's
darth vader is confirmed to appear
during the ahsoka series at some point
maybe be a flashback or some other kind
of like force uh memory or something
like that um so that might be uh obi-wan
kenobi could be a place that ahsoka
could show up in as well um but i i
think it's just more likely uh she she
didn't consider herself worthy of
training the child there would have to
imply some kind of um
partnership some kind of a relationship
or maybe luke was like i can't handle
this student yeah we need we got to
bring in it he's telling me he's too
wild
he's too unruly yeah but i would love if
uh there's some kind of implied um a
relationship between ahsoka and luke you
know i knew your dad uh and uh and maybe
like uh ahsoka could have been someone
who helped luke continue his training
right during uh yeah period all right
tommy what's our next question about the
book of boba fett uh our next what the
fat question is what the fed is the
future of star wars storytelling we
touched on it a little bit earlier but
yeah i mean it's all going to depend on
um how much i think people really love
the book of boba fett i honestly think
when obi-wan kenobi comes out later this
year that's going to be the big show
that everyone talks about but it kind of
tells us that there are two eras maybe
three eras that uh filoni and kathleen
kennedy and the star wars creative team
are exploring you have the pre-ot and
the post ot right before the original
trilogy and then like right after the
original trilogy you have um the
pre-original trilogy stories like
obi-wan kenobi that's gonna be between
revenge of the sith and uh before a new
hope uh cassian andor that's gonna be
leading up to rogue one uh you might see
the lando calrissian series during this
time as well yeah uh we don't we know
there's gonna be a lando show
i would think donald glover era of lane
yeah that's what i was gonna be the one
yeah um but we also know of the acolyte
and they just cast it sounds like a
mandala stenberg as its lead and that's
going to be taking place during the
final years of the high republic era so
that would set that before potentially
the prequels before the clone wars
erupted um so that would be you know
early years of qui-gon jinn yeah that's
that's early early years but then we
also have this other era of right after
return of the jedi that's when the
mandalorian take place boba fett the
ahsoka series that she's hunting down
thrawn he's gonna take place that but we
also know of like
we could see a lando calrissian series
that uh has billy d williams yeah as the
the era because they had that little
moment at the end of uh the rise of
skywalker where lando's talking with
janna and it kind of seemed like they
were potentially spinning that off to be
a new thing we haven't heard anything
about that just because the studio
doesn't really seem to know what lessons
they have learned from the rise of
skywalker right if any at all other than
it seems like this third rail that they
don't want to touch because like you
know we had patty jenkins who's gonna
direct rogue squadron and that's just
been like indefinitely delayed we don't
know when or if that's ever gonna come
out right we had rangers of the new
republic that was going to be a series
with potentially gina carano
that has been shelved
but she's making a movie with ben
shapiro so she's fine that's right yes
her career is doing fine yeah um but so
yeah it seems like all star wars movies
are in kind of this uncertain place and
it seems like you know kathleen kennedy
george lucas have trusted dave filoni
through these little mini series to kind
of continue the narrative it just seems
like we're not really sure if it's going
to be leaning more towards the later era
or the earlier era
but i think the acolyte has the most
like creative uh creative unrestricted
future absolutely in which to explore
and not feel worried that they'd overlap
or contradict any other events from the
prequels but which one are you more
excited to see more of this kind of
ahsoka mando grogu era
i really love that because to me
it's also i mean ahsoka i mean with
grogu and mandaloria these are two new
characters that we had no
knowledge of their existence so
everything they're doing is new star
wars content without any destiny you
know what i mean like we don't know
we know with most of the other
characters what their destiny is you
know at least up until um rise of
skywalker anyway or or you know in any
of the animated shows or or things like
that i'm just loving yeah i'm really
excited for obi-wan kenobi i think that
that i think you're right i think that
show is gonna be absolutely massive i am
very excited for that show and uh yeah i
mean it's just such a great time to be a
fan of new
star wars stories right like oh my god
there's just so much coming out and they
really have a grasp in the tv
world anyway
of what makes star wars so fun they do
such a they really they
they have such a high batting average
with these episodes of like this is even
the ones that are just kind of
adventure one episode one-off adventure
episodes are still fun star wars
adventures if you're a fan of of the
tone and and in the world of star wars
like they're just each one is like a
little 35 minute movie and they they
keep it simple they they celebrate the
production design they really have a
good sense of tone they put a guy in a
nice sensible pair of denims in the
background every once in a while
and then take them out
but i think like to me
um the
shows like obi-wan ken kenobi what clone
wars was what bad batch seems to be is
what i like to call like prequel
redemption for
fans who think that the prequels were
unfairly maligned i thought they did a
lot of good things to contribute to star
wars lore it's like felony taking all
these cool things that were made for the
prequels and telling new stories with
them and that seems to be what obi wan
kenobi is it's
even though i think um uh revenge of the
sith is still a great movie that holds
up and gets better and better with each
rewatch and i think
obi-wan kenobi is going to be like uh
the follow-up to revenge of the sith
that uh that tells other people like no
there there was a great relationship
here that's going to be explored further
yeah whereas it seems like what we love
about the mandalorian is it just feels
fresh and it feels like a redux and i i
think that's what they want to explore
with the book of boba fett uh other
things from the original trilogy really
really going back to the early days and
just exploring that world a little bit
further um i get a little nervous any
time they start to approach things that
feel like first order early days yeah i
i don't want it i kind of want them to
take their time and then each episode
takes place just the next day or like a
week later or something
um because i i was just at galaxy's edge
in disneyland and i loved it like what
they built for it is so cool but my one
uh my one note and i'm hoping that like
disney and lucasfilm is considers this
in the future is it just spent so much
time steeped in the resistance era of
star wars uh i love uh rise of the
resistance as a ride but like so much of
it is like kylo ren focused and i i
think it would be an easy switch in like
early later versions of that ride just
to make it darth vader who chases you
through a starship you know yeah um but
that's you know uh whatever i i think
overall these production designers are
so talented and and i don't i am not one
of these star wars fans who believes
that we should de-canonize the uh sequel
trilogy that we should can pretend like
it never happened no if we pretty yeah
no
uh keep the prequel trilogy as official
star wars canon we have to consider the
sequel trilogy as a star wars canon i
agree but like if we want to celebrate
any particular era of the star wars uh
nunology let's go back to the original
trilogy and that seems to be what the uh
book of boba fett and what the
mandalorian is doing and that's i think
why so many people just kind of
universally love these stories
absolutely yeah all right so let's move
on here
could this series follow ahsoka's search
for thrawn
and if that is something that this
series does who should play thrawn
besides you or i if they don't go to us
i'm gonna play brawn
i'm just gonna play john yeah like hey
you're gonna play john
yeah if ahsoka shows up on this show i
think they're gonna have to give us a
bit more about
what exactly she wants from thrawn
because that was such a fun detail that
they threw into her episode of the
mandalorian i think it'd be great if
they could just like just hire lars
mickelson to do this he's the guy who
voiced him in star wars rebels he's a
great live-action actor as well it seems
like felony is all about doing this by
having katie sackoff play bo katan in
live action like these actors are so
good at playing both why not have her
yeah
in that role in the same way that i
think freddy prince jr in live action
could be great as well i agree uh
playing his character you know like i
think they gotta get i really want
freddie prince junior to get a chance to
be in the live-action star wars thing
because he's such an authentic nerd in
real life too like yeah he'd be great
he'd be great come on and i think what
we have found with the mandalorian is
like yes pedro pascal is is a known
actor but you don't have to have his
face on screen all the time like the
real star of these shows is the universe
is the production design it's the music
is is all the stuff that we loved about
star wars you don't need big name actors
uh to get people to tune in no so
just celebrate the world you've already
built yeah and i and i think no one gets
that better than dave pelosi i agree i
think he's got such a good grasp on yeah
what is what is important and what is
not now um let's talk about uh the
character of omega coming out a bad
batch um i think a lot of people who
watch clone wars watch bad batch but
there's a lot of people who watch the
mandalorian who did not watch bad match
who just don't watch a lot of the
animated series do we think that if they
were to introduce omega in live action
that that might be too much of a
i don't know like a whiplash for just
the live-action viewers yeah i mean are
they gonna be like wait boba fett has a
sister like are they just gonna you know
what all of the animated characters that
have shown up in the tv shows i haven't
watched much of clone wars or rebels and
i knew who ahsoka tano was and i knew
who uh um bogatan was and i knew you
know those characters
were not like new to me like i was like
i didn't have to be like who are they
so i i mean maybe with a little more
omega prepping maybe we just need to get
a little more
omega in the in the atmosphere so people
know that character and then you can
introduce live action without any sort
of who the hell is this reaction right
you as i think it's all about the
character's reintroduction right so
ahsoka tano had such a badass
introduction in that episode you just
see her sabers lighting up in the mist
right or the smoke
and then you have uh bo katan's
introduction was awesome in that episode
of the mandalorian now she's leading the
night owls and she's just a fierce
warrior so i think that we would need
something similar with uh with an adult
version of omega michelle ong voiced her
on bad batch
i've seen some fan casting for the
actress frankie adams from the expanse
who's a samoan new zealand actress uh
who could who could play a version okay
of uh of omega in live action that could
be really fun yeah i think it'd be uh
like
if felonies just stick into his guns and
what he has done with these other things
like introduce these characters in live
action as a way to get people to go back
on disney place and maybe watch
something serious brilliant i think
bringing in omega in live action i don't
i i'd be excited to see that especially
if if boba fett's now trying to build a
new crime empire what is what does any
godfather or tony soprano want more than
having a new dynasty that's right well i
wanted to ask you tommy do you think we
will ever learn how boba fett escaped
from the sarlacc yes is that just going
to be a mystery that they keep you know
no it's very simple it's thanks to our
friends at blue chew and manscape
uh no i i i thought maybe i was wrong i
thought they released like a quick
little piece of footage of like part of
the sarlacc like sarlacc like flopping
out of the pit like implying that like
it had been severed yeah they've had uh
like different stories that have kind of
explained it or implied it right like uh
but are we gonna finally get boba fett
explaining i think we have to i think
they have to it's like you know it's
like quint on on the jo the boat in jaws
you got to have that like there's got to
be a moment when boba fett's sitting
down with his boots up on the table
and he's like you know they never
thought i'd get out of that pit
and we're like they're like bubba you
tell this story what they should do is
they should then zag and be like boba
you've told us this story a million
times and then just not tell us the
viewer what i want is boba to have like
infinite versions of the story that he
keeps telling like joker and dark knight
he's like oh you want to know how he got
these scars well
my father was a jedi i fell into a time
board test in the belly of the sarlacc
went back in time killed a star like
when he was a baby and then like back to
the presents and i was just in a sandy
pit in the middle of nowhere that's what
i want
well that is it for this week's episode
of wookie leaks we are gonna be back
we're back baby uh days from now
wednesday december 29th with our
reaction to the premiere of the book of
boba fett and hopefully some of these
questions will start to be answered
don't forget to check out our many great
merch options at new rockstarsmerch.com
follow me at eavos follow tommy at tommy
bechdold follow new rockstar subscribe
to wikileaks wherever you get your
podcasts thank you for watching and
we
have spoken
[Music]
you